and come to TEDx you always think about
technology the world changing becoming
more innovative think about the
driverless you know there's a everyone's
talking about driverless cars these days
and I love the concept of a driverless
car but when I go in one you know I want
it really slow I want access to the
steering wheel and the brake just in
case right I don't know about you I am
NOT ready for a driverless bus I'm not
ready for a driverless airplane how
about a driverless world and I ask you
that because we're increasingly in one I
mean it's it's not supposed to be that
way that we're number one the United
States is large and in charge right
Americanization and globalization for
the last several generations have
basically been the same thing right I
mean whether it's the World Trade
Organization or it's the IMF the World
Bank the Bretton Woods Accord on
currency these were American
institutions our values our friends our
allies our money our standards that was
the way the world worked so it's sort of
interesting if you want to look at how
the US looks here it is this is this is
our view of how the world is run
president Obama has got the red carpet
he goes down Air Force One and it feels
pretty good it feels pretty comfortable
well I don't know how many of you saw
the China trip last week and the g20 oh
my god right I mean this is how we
landed for the most important meeting of
the world's leaders in China the
national security adviser was actually
spewing expletives on the tarmac no red
carpet kind of left out the the bottom
of the plane along with all the media
and everybody else
um later on in the g20 well there's
Obama hi George hi Norman
they look like they're about to get into
a cage match right and and they did it
was 90 minutes long and they talked
about Syria that's what Putin wanted to
talk about he's increasingly calling the
shots he's the one willing to do stuff
there I mean there's not a lot of mutual
like or trust uh but it's not as if the
Americans are telling him what to do
well how about when the whole twenty are
getting together then surely when the
leaders are all on stage then the
Americans are pulling their weight uh-oh
shishun ping seems fine Angela Merkel
has she always does that look at the but
she always does that
um but Putin's telling turkish President
Erdogan what to do and Obama's like
what's what's going on over there you
see and it's not the problem is it's not
a g20 the problem is it's a g0 world
that we live in a world order where
there is no single country or alliance
that can meet the challenges of global
leadership the g20 doesn't work
the g7 all of our friends that's history
so globalization is continuing goods and
services and people in capital are
moving across borders faster and faster
than ever before
but Americanization is not so if I've
convinced you of that I want to do two
things with the rest of this talk I want
to talk about the implications of that
for the whole world I'll go around it
and then I want to talk about what we
think right here in the United States
and in New York so why what do they
implicate why are we here well we're
here because uh the United States right
I mean we spent two trillion dollars on
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan that were
failed we don't want to do that anymore
we have large numbers of middle and
working classes that feel like they've
not benefited from promises of
globalization
so we don't want to see it particularly
and we have an energy revolution where
we don't need OPEC or the Middle East
the way we used to we produce all that
right here in the United States so the
Americans don't want to be the global
Sheriff for security or the architect of
global trade the Americans don't want to
even be the cheerleader of global values
well then you look to Europe and the
most important alliance in the world has
been the transatlantic relationship but
it is now weaker than it has been at any
point since World War two all of the
crises the brexit conversations the
hedging going on between the French and
the Russians or the Germans and the
Turks or the Brits and the Chinese China
does want to do more leadership they do
but only in the economic sphere and they
want their own value standards currency
in competition with that of the US the
Russians want to do more leadership you
see that in Ukraine in the Baltic States
in the Middle East but not with the
Americans they want their own
preferences in order that's why we are
where we are so what happens going
forward let's start easy with the Middle
East
you know I left a little out but you get
the general idea look there are three
reasons why the Middle East has had
stability such as it is right one is
because there was a willingness to
provide some level of military security
by the US and allies number two it was
easy to take a lot of cheap money out of
the ground because oil was expensive and
number three was no matter how bad the
leaders were the populations were
relatively quiescent they didn't have
the ability and many didn't have the
will to really rise up against well I
can tell you in a g0 world all three of
those things are increasingly not true
and so failed States terrorism refugees
and the rest does the entire Middle East
fall apart
no the Kurds will do better in Iraq
Israel Iran over time but generally
speaking it's not a good look okay how
about this guy all right
he's playing a poor hand very well
there's no question he's hitting above
his weight but long term I didn't mean
that but long term long term if you
think that the Russians were antagonized
by the US and Europe expanding NATO
right up to their borders when we said
they were going to and the EU
encroaching them just wait until the
Chinese put hundreds of billions of
dollars in every country around Russia
they thought they had influence the
Chinese are going to dominate it the
Russians are picking up the crumbs in a
g0 world this is going to be a very
tense 10 years for mr. Putin it's not
all bad right
Asia actually looks a lot better there
are real leaders across Asia they have a
lot of political stability they're there
for a while mr. Modi in India mr. Abbey
who's probably about to get a third term
written in the Liberal Democratic Party
in Japan of course she's in ping who's
consolidating enormous power most
powerful leader in China since Mao
those are the three most important
economies in Asia now look there
problems in Asia we see the sparring
over the South China Sea we see that Kim
jong-un just in the last couple days
tested yet another nuclear weapon right
but the leaders in Asia do not feel the
need to wave the flag to go xenophobic
to actually allow escalation of the
geopolitical and cross-border tensions
they want to focus on long-term economic
stability and growth and that's what
they're actually doing let's turn to
Europe Europe does look a little scared
in this environment so much of what's
happening in the Middle East is washing
up quite literally onto European Shores
you see brexit and you see the concerns
of populism across all of the European
states let me tell you that over the
long term in a g0 world European
expansion will be seen to have gone too
far Europe went right up to Russia went
right down to the Middle East and if the
world were truly becoming more flat and
more Americanized that would be less of
a problem but in a g0 world those
countries nearest Russia and nearest the
Middle East actually have different
economic capabilities different social
stability and different political
preferences and systems than core Europe
so Europe was able to truly expand under
the g7 but under the g0 Europe will get
smaller core Europe around Germany and
France and others will still work be
functional stable wealthy integrated but
the periphery countries like Greece and
Turkey and others will not look that
good at all Latin America a lot of
populism made the economies not go so
well they had been more opposed to the
United States for decades increasingly
they're coming back we see that in
Argentina we see with the openness in
Cuba we will see it in Venezuela with
Maduro Falls will seal in Brazil after
the after the impeachment and when we
finally see
new legitimate president elected they're
the only place you see that that is
moving in another direction is the
unpopularity of Mexican president Pena
Nieto there you could actually see a
slip away from the United States over
the coming years u.s. election matters a
lot on that one to Africa right a lot of
people have said it's going to be
Africa's decade finally in a g0 world it
is absolutely an amazing time for a few
African countries those governed well
with a lot of urbanization a lot of
smart people women really getting into
the workforce entrepreneurship taking
off but for most of the countries in
Africa it's going to be a lot more dicey
extreme climate conditions both
radicalism both from Islam and also
Christianity very poor governance
borders you can't defend lots of forced
migration those countries can fall off
the map so really going to see an
extreme segregation going on between the
winners and the losers across Africa ok
finally back to the United States what
do I think about us because there are a
lot of upset people not here at TEDx I
know but in the United States my god
after 15 months of campaigning we should
be upset I understand that but a lot of
people upset because they say
Washington's broken we don't trust the
establishment we hate the media heck
even globalists like me am i taking it
on the chin look I think we have to
recognize my fellow campers right that
when you are being chased by the bear in
the global context you need not outrun
the bear you need only outrun your
fellow campers
now I just told you about our fellow
campus right and from that perspective
we look okay a lot of people in that
context say let's go dollar
let's go New York real estate let's send
our kids to American universities you
know our neighbors are awesome Canada
Mexico in two big bodies of water
you know how much Turkey would love to
have neighbors like that those are
awesome neighbors terrorism is a problem
in the United States God knows we know
it here in New York but it's a much
bigger problem in Europe than the u.s.
it's a much bigger problem in the Middle
East than it is in Europe these are
factors of large magnitude we just
accepted 10,000 Syrian refugees and
we're complaining bitterly about it
right you know why because they can't
swim here right I mean the Turks would
love to have only 10,000 Syrian refugees
the Jordanians the Germans the Brits
right it that's not the situation that's
that's the reality of the United States
now that sounds pretty good here's the
challenge in a g0 world the way you lead
is by example if we know we don't want
to be the global cop anymore if we know
we're not going to be the architect of
global trade we're not going to be the
cheerleader global values we're not
going to do it the way we used to the
21st century is changing we need to lead
by example be so compelling that all
these other people are going to still
say it's not just they're faster campers
even when the bear is not chasing us
this is a good place to be we want to
emulate them the election process this
year is not proving a good option for
leading by example Hillary Clinton says
it's going to be like the 90s we can
still be that cheerleader on values we
can still be the architect of global
trade we can still be the global Sheriff
and Donald Trump wants to bring us back
to the 30s he's saying our way or the
highway you don't like it lump it right
I mean neither are recognizing a
fundamental truth the g0 which
is that even though the u.s. is not in
decline it is getting objectively harder
for the Americans to impose its will
even have great influence on the global
order are we prepared to truly lead by
example what would we have to do to fix
this after November after the next
president comes in well either we have
to have another crisis that forces up to
respond a depression would do that
another global financial crisis could do
this god forbid another 9/11 could do
that or absent crisis we need to see
that the hollowing out the inequality
the challenges that are growing and
growing in the United States are
themselves urgent enough to force our
leaders to change and that we have those
voices through our cell phones
individually we have those voices to
compel them to change there is of course
the third choice perhaps the most likely
one which is that we do neither of those
things and in four years time you invite
me back and I will give this speech yet
again thank you very very much